hello freak [ __ ] cultures he work
with this girl Susan for years that
helped you get a different perspective
oh you know what I didn't think it right
I didn't think that way yeah you're
right but I saw that kind of [ __ ] now
look ultimately you get on the set
you're gonna do what you're doing the
directors gonna hey Steve you know you
shouldn't be so angry there what
whatever you know he thinks and the guy
that wrote it you know what I mean but I
work very hard at it and I worked for
years now now don't forget I'm making a
living for 16 years as an actor hey I
left the Riviera in 2000 is that crazy
yeah sixteen years so and I've done a
lot of [ __ ] this is you saying that mm
was 16 years ago what yeah is that right
yeah listen II I started on The Sopranos
in 99 I went back and forth for a year
you know I didn't quit I did six
episodes I was still at the rib what is
it like how it must have been [ __ ]
strange I was still at the river then I
booked it for ten years I can I booked
the river till 2010 Chris Rock said you
still dipping your toe in that [ __ ] I
said why not they paid me what the [ __ ]
how hard as hard is it to [ __ ] a book
three comics a week I could do it in
three days booked up six months that's
hilarious
you know the book I booked guys that uh
you know that didn't work much you know
well I think your point is the really
important part of what you're saying is
like the getting a different perspective
or a guy like Gandolfini you would you'd
imagine he was so good you would imagine
that he probably looked at it from all
sorts of different angles yes he did and
you saw a lot of different colors but he
you know he would work 16 hours okay
16-hour days on The Sopranos he's in
he's there so I mean the guy gets up
whatever time he got up then he's got to
go home and learn tomorrow stuff so
sometimes he told me he'd be sitting in
the chair he fall asleep for two hours
he wakes up she's still there just
waiting for him to wake up and they're
gonna work on this stuff for tomorrow
whoa yeah and then and nine months of
that don't forget you know The Sopranos
Joe they were when I got on the show was
like eight days I came on the second
season so it was like eight days for an
episode then nine and ten at the last
season it was we that we shot nine shows
in nine months holy [ __ ] yeah
was like shooting a movie there's no
commercial so it's a full hour but you
know that's what it was man it was long
it was like shooting a movie Wow my
month and Episode III the first episode
was 1718 working days Lorraine Bracco
said to me you're gonna work more in
this episode that I will the whole
season cuz she only worked one day an
episode you know she had the greatest
job in show business why he shot that in
one day oh that's beautiful for her you
know was a great part too
yeah it was great you know but III think
the coaching wise and I think a lot of
it is you know your focus you
concentrating know your stuff know your
lines I mean you're an actor you know
know your [ __ ] don't come in and be like
a smartass yeah maybe I paraphrase know
your stuff respect what's on the page
you know that I'm a big believer in that
yeah on the Sopranos you didn't have
lived the word thaw and I'm not joking
you there was there was a time that I
had to say I gotta go and the line was I
have to go and they kept correcting me
and correcting me correct cuz I just you
know I gotta go I have to go I don't
know why what when I didn't question it
right I mean you know but that's a crazy
amount of work where you're talking
about Gandolfini that's really that's
still [ __ ] with my head yeah now
listen Jim was one of my closest friends
couldn't find the better guy he worked
it hardly saw his kids you know his kid
you know his daughter wasn't born you
know while he was on uh Sopranos but it
was like no life you could completely
gave up your life if not the rest of us
because there were so many characters
you know I didn't I had a couple
episodes where I worked a real lot but
you know other words just can't be good
for your health
well it was a lot of guys I mean I
remember ed I think Jimmy Smits I read
years ago NYPD he said he couldn't take
it was 18 18 hour days yeah and yeah
he's making a fortune he said I couldn't
do it anymore
ya know I've had friends that have been
on dramas before and there's the same
thing they would tell me that just they
just couldn't do it they just they would
and they would just they would be at
when the season would wrap their to go
this has got to be my last season yes
you know it's appointment to money now
you know the thing what I love about
Blue Bloods is there's a lot of
characters for this different story so
it's not like that on my signature whoa
it's hanging up it's it's you know like
seven of us but it's not my signature
how crazy is uh someone's gonna fake the
signature I'm hanging up on a nice
restaurant
Bobby baccala with a fat fake stomach
it's from the days when I wore the fat
stone oh they made you put like a
prosthesis - yeah yeah then I got fat
enough on my did you get fat enough just
after wear that no though one day chaser
you know I I you know when I first got
the role I was seeing all these jokes
like you cows on with legs and your fat
fart can you thinking I'm going I'm not
that much fatter than gay and Afeni I
start to think that maybe they cast the
wrong guy I'm not joking I'm saying
could that be I mean these jokes don't
make sense and then they call though you
got to come in for a fat suit so I
wasn't ridiculous thing then the second
year they made it like a really nice one
that cost for like a costume shop it had
like tits and had a costume shop in like
a Broadway custom thing and and then one
year I was going back and I was at a
fitting for the the fourth year you know
worked in the next year and he looked at
me man hey you know if the way that
anymore I said alright so I'll be silly
it was pretty embarrassing at first I
was prancing around there they had an
ass on me too like a big ass go figure
yeah and he was gonna too big and I was
like going walking back and forth like
raising Christ
it's [ __ ] humiliating Steve Landis
Bergman 2 , he said to me today X your
permission to do that I said no stevie's
I want the [ __ ] day that I want well
I want to get the job you know that was
a weird time when The Sopranos came out
because all the sudden there was like a
lot of fake mob guys a lot of fake
connected guys fake Italian you know I
mean still around I call it gay Guinea
Actors Guild
but you don't I mean it's like that
acting that way became in fashion they
started it tasted they used to hang
around wherever we were
around they were extras it was a day
they're still around but there was you
know we did a appearance in the casino
we just do a lot of that stuff you know
they were everywhere they were
everywhere they were hoping to get on
the show come on you did the shot it
doesn't how to do the show no I remember
Michael Imperioli one time we were up in
Reno and there was one of them guys he
was playing blackjack and well you know
and except come on put me on the show I
could though you do I had Michael just
went off on who I've been [ __ ] John
for twenty years you know bump up I've
been acting did you do you know him he
got he hit Michael and Michael was right
he got really pissed off this is just
one of those [ __ ] goombas you know
and the guy could do what you do yeah
they're the worst
exactly it's like this there's wannabes
but there's something about guinea
wannabes this allows it's a handful out
here oh yeah there's planning the thing
here they congregate together when they
try to like Clara Hou Italian together
what's the last thing Rogan how come you
got Rogan what the book I kind of try to
navigate away from oh the brutal well
being even in New York I kind of that's
not my thing
well Sopranos was so good that it almost
killed the mob genre you know I think so
I think you're right about that cuz you
know what unless and I get a lot of
scripts Joe you know of that crap you
know they make these I call them
backyard movies you know yeah never
gonna see them you know it up getting
paid I'm not interested cuz it's that
same thing I'll [ __ ] you or break you
[ __ ] man do you know I am you know my
uncle is like a doll my rarest cat but
it's true but they write this and I say
how just people give them the money how
do you get the money to make these
movies well I think for a while people
are making them just cuz it Sopranos was
so popular now unless you're gonna beat
Sopranos Goodfellas you know what's the
great mob movies surprise I was shot
around good those Cocina see no way a
Raging Bull had mob Florence right great
movie what am I missing there was just a
few you know some great you know great
great mob movies but now I was after The
Sopranos I mean
you don't see no the Godfather got for
the right to know there was some but
you're gonna have to beat that then they
tried they tried to do some Mabi stuff
every Donovans work and that's a good
show that's a good show when that's from
an Irish perspective yeah well I think
what happened with those movies was or
that show rather is it was those you had
a movie every week exactly
so like every subject was covered
betrayal gambling it was funny
murder was funny funny funny elements it
was very smart that was something you
know I would go I would be around and
people go I don't like that show you our
number time have you ever seen the show
have you ever seen the show no I haven't
seen it I guess I guess for somebody I I
don't I don't watch porn I hate porn
have you ever seen it no well then how
do you know you don't like it or did you
see it or do you watch it you know what
I mean but secretly they're holding
signs up by with no porn
well that was a big thing right the
Italian American society was testing
against it about this story I wrote a
kids book Nicky deuce okay it took place
in Brooklyn and we turned it into a
movie for Nickelodeon you know which I
we didn't wanted again the Phoenix
lesser movies and I had Michael
Imperioli in and
sirico and and Nickelodeon made the
movie but when I was when I wrote the
book I was doing book signings and you
know it's about a kid fish-out-of-water
who goes back to Brooklyn he grew up in
the suburbs and he winds up with a kid
entire neighborhood Bensonhurst in
Brooklyn and then he gets into some
mischief I don't even call it trouble
but so this guy kept writing letters and
[ __ ] and killing me on the internet and
writing letters to the bookstores ahead
of me getting there
you know like saying hey he's you know -
auditory against Italians and he's now
he's bringing kids into it blah blah
blah blah blah so finally I get the
guy's number and I call the guy I swear
to you I say to him listen these name is
a I think his name is Anthony I said
listen Anthony buh-buh-buh-buh this
isn't the world I know like rappers rap
about what they know this is what I know
you know and
he said to me I said you know what can I
do
tell me what I can do let's fix this I
mean cuz you know you know Papa bah he
saw you can make a donation to my
organization it was the italian-american
[ __ ] I said you gotta be kidding me
a hunger ball to stop trying to shake me
down and there's a whole bunch of when
the movie came out we got some heat for
the Nicky deuce movie really and it's
not really about mob it's just one
tension I mean exactly
you know and they did that with the
surprise but people would say all the
time you know Joe uh yeah I don't watch
the thing I'm an Italian you guys talk
bad about Italians you know they didn't
they they showed what really was I
thought it was very authentic you know
oh well The Sopranos is authentic as it
gets if you know anybody like that you
know those people exist absolutely and I
contend they don't exist is it fence
exactly I think it was a story that need
to be told I don't yeah yeah we put the
Italians down this is what it is but was
such a fascinating show because
Gandolfini was a bad guy like his
character Donna Wong yeah you rooted for
a bad guy a murderer for a murderer who
cheated on his wife stole robbed shook
people down to Lily but he was your guy
he was I think the first I think I could
be wrong the first like antihero that
people really fall into I think you're
right
III can't imagine for that it was you
know your root for the guy you know he
was a real antihero a murderer a conman
I mean all the above all they didn't
just do it to people in the mob they did
it to people you know like on the show
there wasn't just within each other yeah
they went outside they were robbing
people yeah and busting up you know
businesses and doing all the stuff that
they do yeah it was great show was good
very small it was a very small show and
if it were if they put it back on now
they would get higher ratings than some
of their shows now I probably bet they
would it's well it's so good I think a
lot of people forgot how good it was and
it also changed a lot if you go to the
first episode the first episode was
essentially like a slapstick comedy
remember that no I know you know
lorraine brought not lorraine bracco who
was the woman that played uh his wife
Edie Falco Edie Falco Edie Falco had a
[ __ ] machine gun and like the
daughter was trying to spend down seated
and she's outside with a machine gun
pointing at her it was way more
slapstick it was weird it was like a
comedy when they shot the the show aired
in 99 right
I think they shot that like in 98 if I'm
not mistaken really if I'm not mistaken
at 98 I believe on 97 even they go back
and then it took six months and then
they started shooting them you know how
how David chase did it he didn't do it
like a regular show where you shoot it
and then in three weeks it's on the air
you know he put them all on the can they
were finished and locked and you know
you know what I mean like you know you
finished you yours or whatever it took
nine months and then he edited them and
bah bah bah bah bah and then they aired
you know it's done a completely
different way Wow you know also they
would they would you know if they didn't
like what you did I mean he replace you
and you never even knew it really
he was place here you know like I think
I had a scene with a guy and they call
back you know a month or so later and so
you got to shoot the scene again with a
different actor for whatever reason
whether you know the guy didn't do a
good job or he looked too young or too
old or just didn't fit he had the he had
the capacity to just shoot it again if a
scene didn't work he rewrite the scene
you shoot the scene again you know three
months later what's interesting about
those kind of shows too is that they're
so big and so popular that you become
that character whoever that character is
you become that guy and you're that guy
forever well that's of course I mean
that and that that's part a deal that's
okay I had no career before that so it's
not yeah I'm not saying with you what
I'm saying like there's some people
that'll be like you've worked since then
you'll continue to work but there's some
people that were on that show that were
really famous when that show was on the
air and they vanished yeah yeah yeah
well you're in the you know you've got
people all over the
world watching I mean I've been stopped
with people literally Oh from all over
the world that have watched his show it
was like a cult hit like nothing that
ever hit before like big [ __ ] big
[ __ ] for the rest of his [ __ ] yeah yeah
some of Vinnie's also he embraces that
too
you know what I mean right Grace's dad
for him and it works and right he's okay
he works he does his things no he's
always gonna work he's a very good out
yeah he's got his music he's a musician
and stuff but I I hear you
especially the name big [ __ ] that was a
big thing what people like to say that
yeah yeah they do like say that but also
his you know the scene in the movie when
they kill him like the whole the whole
way it plays out it was very intense
it's like whoa I can't believe they kill
big [ __ ]
well that was the big thing boil early
it was the first time to a regular cast
member gets killed yeah I mean they're
not killing the you know the guy from
friends Wow exactly David Schwimmer
ain't getting killed you know oh one
year one Friday night oh my god they
killed David Schwimmer there's five
friends don't you know so that was a big
character that gets killed and then big
Carrodus kept getting killed which is
why guys were worried I mean it was a
real concern that you were gonna get
killed off the show the more material
they gave you yeah the more of a shot
you're getting killed yeah yeah I mean
you know let's not kid ourselves it's
not just you know you're out of work
they just put you out of work in the
biggest show when when Gandolfini killed
Imperioli I was like whoa holy [ __ ]
pinch his nose there well like what but
but you know what once you made it into
the last season it was like a listen you
know right you know we're done you're
paid well however the story ends it's
probably better if I would have got
killed early on I would have felt really
shitty I'll tell you and so all the
stuff that happened cuz you know right
you know what I mean I press you know we
didn't major we started making money
towards the middle in the end you know
not the guys at the beginning were
making all money well those shows are
hard to make money right they like HBO
is nothing don't worry
get HBO pace and they pay now even
better than the shows off the end nine
years Wow no you know we're going to you
know and then there was other
coming in because she had the
opportunity to do other [ __ ] you know
well that show was also groundbreaking
and it was one of the first shows like
that and now HBO specializes in those
kind of shows and shows AMC and sold is
Showtime yep
yeah I mean you know that all kind of I
know witness a promise it's the first
time they they're hiring uh you know a
fat bald guy you know Jim wasn't a
leading man right I mean they wanted you
know you figure it's a good-looking mob
guy you know what I mean but he was
intense and charismatic and what a fraud
actor girls girls love them yeah we used
to joke you know they say TV puts ten
pounds on you I say it takes fifty off
you well he was just it was a such an
interesting character he was so intense
and like when he got into that murderous
rage like you [ __ ] bought it hook
line and similarly when you acted with
him you didn't have to uh you know get
enough hacks scared like it was a scene
I got to be scared you gotta yell at me
you know he was [ __ ] you know he gave
you the whole thing yeah well we had
that fight you know me and him had that
fighting the first episode out last
season I mean you know when we shot that
for a day and a half whoa that was tough
he was choking me he said listen well
you know let's try to take this as far
as we can and we [ __ ] turned I was
pulling his hair he was [ __ ] choking
me that I was getting cut from the night
was wearing a you know necklace you know
I was getting cut from that I mean we've
all banged up hanged up for real and
that's why I look real it was like two
fat out of shape guys fine and [ __ ] I
mean they don't you know guys it's not
Steven Seagal I mean you know we look
you you you know what the hell this was
like a fight like so when you do
something like that like how hard you
hit each other you know as hard as you
know you could without really hurt and
then he had said that let's go as far as
we could and we were you know I usually
I say pull my hair pull my hair and all
the [ __ ] phones Aaron he's choking me
go ahead go further you know you know
like I said we you know we're good
friends you you know if you do it with a
stranger you could get a little yeah
funky you know to me like hey well you
know you know